you probably spent your Christmas break
either reading or ignoring an awful lot
of Game of the Year lists which are all
very nice but never really
representative of what you actually
think our People's Choice Award puts the
power back in your hands and now it's
time for the results I'm Kate and this
is your GameSpot news update The Witcher
3 has emerged the emphatic winner of a
GameSpot poll that asked readers to vote
for their favorite game of 2015
fallout 4 took second place while Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain was voted
third best game of the year from
software's ps4 exclusive blood-borne
finished fourth while indie breakthrough
rocket league took fifth
however that list doesn't portray the
extent of The Witcher threes dominance
in the poll the open-world opus amassed
62% of all votes which means it
accumulated more endorsements than all
the other 24 entrants combined by the
final count its lead over second place
fallout 4 was an extraordinary 53
percent the top five finalists closely
resembled GameSpot editors game of the
year list in which Witcher 3 took first
place above rocket League Metal Gear
Solid 5 blood-borne and Super Mario
maker fallout 4 finish in sick meanwhile
in the individual platformer categories
for people's choice game of the year The
Witcher 3 took first on all platforms it
shipped on Xenoblade Chronicles X won
best Wii U game while fallout shelter
was voted best mobile game so does this
list look more like your personal game
of the year list or have we missed
something else out let us know in the
comments or come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw remember to keep
it gamespot.com put all your gaming
updates and thanks for watching